hey guys it's just dated I'm here with
road today this is super exciting so
it's the I guess it's the jellybean
season right now and I thought it'd be
really fun to taste a bunch of jelly
beans and when I was online I bought so
many I even got some of the Buddha they
like the bean boozled oh those are gross
they're really gross so I thought that
we would warm up to the jelly bean case
and start with some good flavors first
so this will be for a separate video
they have beer flavored jelly bean here
shambling doubt it's just so strange I
had never seen those crisps the Queen
I got so excited she brought this over
these are little cocktails and I love
vena cava look at this they have a
strawberry daiquiri mojito there's a lot
on there do people like Gillian's cuz
like I don't really like that I love
candy not like my coaches you do like
that yeah I don't know jelly bean Bowl I
like jelly beans but usually I don't
find these fancy flavors I just have
like the little Jelly Belly like variety
I don't have these like fancy these are
like for a special occasion
well I brought my ax today my mic is
Susie ain't fancy on engraved cuz we
always go on adventures together this is
re I just seen what is that for like
chopping down trees throwing axe what do
you throw that at Target Lea targets
we've got the cocktail classics here we
go whoa
okay what drink would you like taste
tropical and super probable that's
actually quite nice I taste the
pineapple Joe and the coconut I love
them that's one of my favorites
peach Bellini whoa hmm okay so remember
what I said didn't like jelly beans not
delicious I think maybe I didn't realize
that I like them a mojito
whoa that so far is my favorite are they
doing this
I love mojitos it tastes so good I'm a
really good strawberry daiquiri I don't
know if I've had a thought lately like
ever like a real one it tastes delicious
it's just like really got me said a
strawberry wait that's a peach Bellini
it's reversed the labels are reversed on
the back this is a pomegranate Cosmo a
common rule what's a nut Cosmo it's just
like spirit and what cranberry juice
that one's okay I've never had a Cosmo
Oh Cosmo Zwerdling Lee's favorite you
know this pack but all the other ones
were perfect mmm the mojito definitely
my favorite peanut colada was my
favorite for you for later I put them in
their jellybean Bowl oh my gosh these
are going my jelly bean wall didn't know
that I liked jelly beans
weren't they great I think back
everything when I said they're a little
chewy will trick they have a great
flavor I have two big teeth so sometimes
that causes in trouble what happened to
you - I don't know I just never had
teeth that came in when I was a child
they never came though they pulled my
baby tooth out they're like oh you come
my dentist my dentist is great this is a
fabulous five we were the Fab five when
we got going on here there so this is
what we just tried please your cocktail
classics this movie blend
what kind of smoothie looks like we've
got very smoothie orange smoothie this
is just I mean that wasn't so good that
tasted the first it was good
now it tasted like spoiled milk look
Claire did you do oh is that I don't
know your buddy got orange yeah all
right I think it was that one okay I'm
not gonna eat the red I'm gonna try an
orange hmm I don't think I like the
smoothie ones they're like no weird it
is in the beginning has a great taste
the asters a little like spoiling elk
pick mmm skip the smoothie there's a
color cheat on the back give me some
mint mint chocolate chip here we go
favorite ice cream flavor I'll try that
one too Oh
oh my god you're making weird noises are
you okay
it's like weak artificial cream flavor I
think I'm gonna try right the cake
birthday cake ice cream then what do you
mean with that
artificial cream flavor gross I got like
it all right well we should move on to
soda pop grape crush root beer orange
crush 7up dr. pepper I love dr. pepper
we have dr. peppers yes I think that
this is dr. Otis oh my gosh any root
beer and 7up I want to try it dr. pepper
I want to try a root beer which one did
you try how do you know they're both
Brown Oh God oh but that's terrible it's
absolutely disgusting Bubba that hasted
look rotten moldy soils and body parts
Oh dr. pepper was not good what do you
know Troy root beer okay it's not great
it's really light that's what I
appreciate about the flavor is it's like
really white like root beer dr. pepper
just had way too much flavors yeah like
too much artificial flavor like quit
hitting me in the face I didn't like it
she was trying to set it up yeah I love
this Evernote mmm really nice it's super
limey like I feel it in my sinuses I'm
sweating now are these taste like the
SONA though I know that is so why me
when you close soda
I think it's been so I'm talking to em
hmm and what they say I'll try the grape
one but uh bond line was going near the
great I'll do orange actually the rep is
nice orange isn't bad it's hard to mess
up for jelly beans
clearly it's not that hard these aren't
even the gross jelly filled those are in
the bag good jelly big these are the
citrus mix XM kiss the juice I'll try a
lemon well I'm as good or better lemon I
don't know I'm tasting that same Sunkist
better than the service I'm gonna do the
grapefruit even though I don't like
grapefruit at all
I don't like my food either
we just bonded we just had a moment
everybody anyway saw it on camera but we
both don't like grapefruit disease why
the tilt our I don't know but almost
like sour patch kids our it is yes it's
a lie it's a lot well fabulous five is
down be honest well I think that we've
been having so much fun with those
little box containers that we should
really get super silly oh my gosh these
are supposed to be champagne flavored
jelly bean and these are the beers
little is beans let's see if they
actually taste like do you think it's
going to be a light beer or dark beer
pearl
this looks like kind of a light beer I
would say what kind of a port is it
oh that stinks girl what is it like a
bit like your beer first is it like it
smells like dirt and yeast I was pretty
they are this looks like champagne like
it looks all free and your beer first
cuz it's probably gonna be disgusting
let's try beer and then I'll wash the
taste out with maybe one of these
[Music]
it's not like beer boom I actually like
this it's really good and it's really
light I mean this why does it smell so
bad but it tastes just fine
I'm surprised actually I thought this
was gonna be disgusting it's not no it's
good put that in your being to my mind I
was not expecting that after this mouth
champagne
draya's Cheers mmm sweeter I like it
it's so mild yeah the ones that I
thought were gonna be trash a really
good these might be like my favorite
jellybean flavors because it's a very
light it's so light it almost tastes
like um like a grapefruit juice like
like a white a white grapefruit juice I
believe in light okay wake it up okay
what's next flavored is a little scary
jellybeans are pretty I think I'm
starting to like Charlie P they're
really cute so this is from a different
company this isn't the Jelly Belly this
is from just born which they also make
hot tamales and peeps and Mike and I
just born
I read 100 tried the red one which was
cinnamon and now I found the flavors
white is peppermint I will use that to
counteract it
oh the will is really strong cuz we want
strong flavored jelly beans
oh just born they days looking fresh and
strong okay so the yellow one is close
close I can't tell if I love it or hate
it absolutely but strong Wow Wow
what it's a clear delicate it reminds me
of the holidays you know because I
always put
cloves and nutmeg and ginger in together
like when I'm making like you know spice
cookies for the holidays for the big
flashback to holiday videos all right
I'm gonna put this around the tree
okay get all these muscles goodness it
goes really good with these pants so I
left them on the mirror man is green
okay I like spearmint imma blow are you
a mint or a spearmint kind of a person
I'm lost pyramid wouldn't vinegar
wintergreen Brides me
what the heck's a wintergreen I don't
know why oh that's caught wintergreen
it's pink because they ran out of green
I like this I'm gonna go next time I
think that we should try these a Krispy
Kreme Krispy Kreme they also come and
miss back as well it's basically the
same donut flavors but they're okay the
more like pretty display all right we
have original glazed right in the middle
and then we have a glazed blueberry cake
a chocolate ice with sprinkles
strawberry ice and then a cinnamon what
is that joining me on an open-air bath
oh my goodness you need okay go for it
why can you not open anything
cinnamon-apple film this is pretty
pretty over here
this is pretty which one's gonna try the
glaze first yeah a classic yes I have
the original glazed eye window because
this tastes like a straight-up donut I
[Music]
don't like it absolute lie you're
disgusting
okay if you guys get these you'll know
what we're talking about things like a
donut which one which I might really sad
now like are any of them gonna do I
don't know let's try the strawberry
strawberry that one's nice it's a little
creamy it's better than the first one I
mean but if that is what we're basing
all of these off of I think there's like
an underlying flavor like the donut
flavor doesn't they like donut no it's
mixed with any of these is just gonna be
weird
what about your blueberry one oh no
sirree
please don't know how my hopes and
dreams let's try okay fine okay subpar
do any of these taste like a donut why
are you doing this to one there's
finkles in here oh that's funny
what's your favorite kind of donut ever
made honestly look I like these cake
donuts like that type of like like the
old-fashioned with like the glaze yeah
those are crash Donuts I like yeah those
are chocolate covered donut or a maple
bar chocolate 5c hmm no that's not
chocolate doughnut okay we've got one
more it's the cinnamon apple filled and
you were hyped about the cinnamon this
is like Christmas morning and he's Nana
decided
go to your Al's it's like I got a lump
of coal my stocking but he wrapped the
coal you know wrapped it so I thought oh
this could be something and then you
open it oh this one's okay it's just
okay well I'm disappointed I don't want
to see these Krispy Kreme you have great
doughnuts but the jelly beans are not
for me not for me maybe it's for you
we've got two more okay I'm getting
excited again we've got holiday
favorites which eventually could be
expired because the holiday is way over
but Oh fine there's jelly beans I don't
know I've heard all this stuff from
Amazon to do an Oreo unboxing yeah
things expired and spirity I had these
Orioles with like the mega stuf ones
there was like very cookies missing yeah
somebody's like look at that look the
other half of this isn't even there I'm
upset I'm money hitting we had their
little mitts in my cookies Walter
Welch's what are you so Welch's vultures
vultures Fisher's family former owned
yeah let's try the grape hmm I like this
I like these so this is a different
brand as well so which one do we think
is a strawberry I was always say I don't
like grape flavors I like this brand of
great it's just so good grape yeah
because it's family farmer owned
obviously my first brand of grape I've
ever liked today's Hey Oh they also do
strawberry really well
mmm-hmm ice cream so full of flavor
well Wow white grape peach
what's good red ones oh my gosh I think
the yellow is the white grape peach
that's good Wow these are my favorite so
far
my friend that jelly beans put on right
there in your jar these are going in the
good bowl these are so good mmm I don't
know these are my favorite is are really
really good I don't even know which ones
my favorite flavor out of them on the
bottom you're Dennis number plenty to go
have a great day
he's amazing I may be going into some
sort of like sugar coma not sure
we may be way we both sing in a scrim
story by members holiday favorites oh I
love the holidays
me too oh my gosh what oh my gosh they
have eggnog berry pie pie
remember when we tasted all those
pumpkin flavored things it tastes like a
naked Dorito they're really good and I
was like come over I have a few pumpkin
things to try I like 2006 I'm sorry did
you are hope you were hungry oh my gosh
okay
I'll put that one away to never be
tasted again I don't like it it doesn't
taste good it was like a spicy rot a
spicy broth Inc we're over it
all right poo gross again became candy
Keaney and you better not be able to
mess up mint
oh yes why not very nice look okay look
can you just like a piece of gum
it's nice after you just have kind of a
weird pasting on like lens yeah it's
like whoo nice and fresh
okay eggnog I don't really like eggnog
to begin with see I like eggnog so you
tell me if this tastes like a ok I have
a really good eggnog cake recipe Oh
delicious it's fine actually I'm gonna
give it a medium yeah it's so come up
that into it like a little bit wow I
really wish shots make them jellybeans
for no no no but not bad cranberry sauce
is love that oh I might lose everything
make a jelly bean cranberry sauce I have
a great recipe for these too by the way
just throwing out there everybody it's
fresh it's good
I just tastes like your cranberry goes
by like a candy cranberry yeah I got
super sweet what we have next we have
one last one this is our final bean hot
chocolate oh my gosh Cheers
little YB little hot cocoa
[Music]
Wow chocolate because I have a
stomachache at this place I thought
doesn't be so easy because they're so
small
yeah okay can't you see this adds up
this really John's add up I mean CMAC
sugar we budget is alike a lot it would
I had a bad fall oh I don't know let's
not think about it I think probably my
favorite one it was the movie you know I
really liked them AHA so good nice and
minty I like the Pina Colada one and
then my favorite bath with the little
juices if you guys if you're gonna get
any of these I would get the juice one
yeah those were so good also the size
comparison of this bean is apparent to
like the Jelly Belly ones they're a
little bit bigger oh you got a little
bit more of a taste for being I knew get
a lot well I am so glad a video idea I
decided not to bring in the gross one
should we do a video Lauren has you a
follow-up like in three months because I
know Kay talks first well guys thank you
so much for watching Ruth thank you so
much for major sweet tooth so any time
you want to try weird candies or any
flavors I am in like there's not me and
called me as I think this is great well
go check out Rose channel of Alma link
subscription we have so many fun videos
that we've done together and that's it
we'll see you guys later and let us know
if you want us to taste the girls beans
[Music]
[Applause]